if you're a woman freezing your eggs may
seem like a good way to delay having
children to a more suitable time in your
life and our specialist have been urging
women to freeze their eggs in their
early 20s to increase their chances of
having a child but this one you're
asking should women start to rely on
this procedure or here to talk it over
we have the TV personal to 30 plug-ins
and joining us from Dorset the science
on caster dr. emily gross and that's dr.
Emily there and Katie is here with me in
the studio and dr. Emily I'll come to
you first and you won't mind me saying
you froze your eggs at the age of 38
talk me through the process with you
deciding to take this step and why sure
so I got to my mid-30s and everybody
around me was having kids yeah I guess a
lot of people know what that feels like
and I wasn't in a position in my life in
my career in my relationship world to be
having children but I went to a really
amazing talk at the Children's Science
Festival called the fertility timebomb
which really alerted me to the fact that
fertility Drake rates dropped by half
from 35 to 40 half again from 40 to 42
rates of miscarriages go up and I
started to feel really anxious that you
know I wasn't ready to have a child but
I wanted to make sure that in the future
I wouldn't miss out on that chance I was
seeing people around me women around me
of my age rushing into relationships
having kids children with partners who
they were perhaps not quite ready to do
so in relationships ending up not quite
working out being a single parent not
that there's anything wrong with that
and I was seeing women in their late 30s
early 40s meeting the love of their
lives and actually realizing that it was
going to be a real challenge if not
impossible for some of them to conceive
and to have a child and I saw the
devastating impact that that had on
their risks because it's not a guarantee
and that's how it's being sold to a lot
of women Lee no I don't think it's being
sold as a guarantee and I absolutely was
made aware of the risks I did my own
research when I decided to have it done
a few years after that date and I did my
own research I found that the figures I
found out that the success rates are
actually a lot higher than has been put
out in a lot of the tabloid newspapers
if you three directs before the age of
35 it's about a 40% success rate per
cycle which is actually a quaver
if not more - the success rates for IVF
and if you wait till you're over late
30s and 40s it does go down 20-25
percent per cycle but that's still a
pretty high you know chance look
compared to facing the possibility of
not being able to have a killer and
children match and yes there are risks
it's Spencer's okay I think it's
absolutely
well that's dr. Emily's a story and
Katie it's called social egg freezing
because women are having careers now
they're not meeting mr. right in their
20s as they used to you a few decades
ago so a lot of women are going down
this path you don't think it's the right
one no I think this idea is social egg
freezing that's a bizarre phrase in
itself it's more social engineering I
think listening to that lady they're
just talk a whole world of tech and
statistics and numbers and figures and
talk about freezing eggs it's a bizarre
idea you know what happened to just
living your life rolling with the
punches most people's lives including
mine are defined largely by the mistakes
we made and they turn out to be rather
glorious in the end I think women these
days have become especially younger
women have become so prescriptive about
their lives they're used to going on
Bumble or tinder or whatever deciding
how high their boyfriend needs to be how
tall must he be what color hair must he
be what color eyes and now they're
wanting to do the same with their baby
decide what age to have it at I just
think women want too much control and
let's not forget we're talking about
what men do exactly the same thing but
they have the luxury of not having to
worry about the biological term we're
not entirely equal men and women we are
different women now think they can
choose their gender as well it's this
notion you can choose everything in your
life and guess what big news young
people you can't and let's not forget
people talk about harvesting eggs it's
not Cinderella or Snow White skipping
around in the garden amongst the
chickens with their basket plopping eggs
in in the sunshine with birds tweeting
I've had friends who've had this
procedure done they balloon up like
marshmallows they're injected they have
stickers on they have like IVF when we
hear a lot of happy that how stressful
that is on the body I mean really some
of the worse things I've done in my life
have been worked out for the very best
in the end it's really be giving
yourself an option it's a it's like
asking a mate to hold a place in the
queue in case you get there if you've
lived your life and you got to 35
haven't found someone to have kids with
yet it's probably because you're too
uptight to anally retentive about the
way you live your life and you need to
be a bit more flexible take a few risks
live your life big and I say to young
people don't freeze your eggs go out
there find the fun live your life roll
with life's rollercoaster dr. Emily
Katie they're saying there must be
something wrong with you if you haven't
had kids naturally by the time you're in
your 30s I don't think that's the case I
mean Society has evolved and biology
simply hasn't kept up with us you know
that's that that that is evident in so
many different ways about how we're
living our lives now how we're having
families the different family dynamics
that we have the different setups that
we have which are absolutely supportive
of having children of having families
but just at a later age than we used to
be able to so yes women are do you cash
your question do you mind awfully and
have you got children now and how old
are you
no I don't have children now I froze my
eggs at the age of 38 I've been through
a few cycles of increasing and like now
just 10 40 so you're 40 so when you rock
up at the school gate and the rest of
the mums there are 22 are you not gonna
feel like the old geriatric who's
grandma's come to pick up her children
that day and is it not bizarre that
you've chosen to put your body through
this just because you couldn't find
someone to have children with earlier I
don't think it's bizarre at all I think
that if I had had children earlier in
life I wouldn't have had the wisdom the
emotional maturity the financial
stability and actually the real desire
to have them having arthritis and having
children is not hold on you can have
everything when you have children and
that's okay young people seem to think
you need to know everything these days
you don't Katie we are living longer
though people are living well into their
80s at 9 we are living longer but that
doesn't mean you need to have a
geriatric as a mother I've seen the old
ppaos is a geriatric when you're over 30
having a child what what age me you have
your first child well I had my first
child at 28 I know I need to be cautious
geriatric were you under the NHS they
feel like a geriatric half the time and
what I certainly wouldn't want to do at
my humble age of 43 and I know most
viewers think I'm 65 is I would not be
want to be staggering to the school
playground with my arthritis just
because I didn't have the perfect moment
to meet someone I think what's happened
is we
become so choosy about their partner no
one's ever good enough and they've
forgotten to find the fun in life go out
and make mistake okay dr. Emily I'm one
of the cheesy ones apparently so I'm
with you on this one speak up for us
choosing women have you had how are you
I'm 40 I'm just 10 40 I know you gonna
are you scared that you won't for
children
no I've chosen not to freeze my eggs but
dr. Emily has and you still you're still
holding out hope absolutely I have a
wonderful life I have I'm super fit I'm
super healthy and it did you enjoy you
acted did you enjoy the moment did you
enjoy the process
no it's harvested you did enjoy it I did
I know well she's she's empowered she
feels like she's doing something about
it would that be a fair assessment
you're not empowered if you're having
your eggs drugged I'm a bully you're
empowered if you live a baby a very easy
life a lot of happy children my children
are very happy okay well both are
leading very happy lives in very
different ways dr. Emily grant thank you
so much seasonal egg egg yolk a Katie
Hopkins thank you very much